Janine teags I've been teaching here at
Abbott Elementary for a year now the
staff here is incredible finally feeling
this half of things cheesesteak
this is a classroom not a hoagie stand
we had it on the board
yeah the inspiration from the show was
kind of watching my mom as a
Philadelphia school teacher for 40 years
and just watching that journey and also
friends of mine who are teachers now you
know that inspired me kind of knowing
that there was so much story there for
season two I think I would say my
friends are even more of the inspiration
because they're still teaching my mom is
retired but I have friends who are
teaching now and you know just their
journey is fascinating to me and it's
inspirational on its own what they're
able to do every day season two I think
will be filled with more examples of
their stories
okay so if the store has 10 potatoes
right and you take away two of them how
many potatoes would the store have left
Janine what did I say about taking my
potatoes from the lunchroom but visual
learning is so much better but guess
what now you have zero potatoes
the office in parks and rec were huge
for me and but still even though I was
they were huge for me I was a fan and I
didn't necessarily develop other shows
with my community in mind this one I was
sitting at my mom's desk when I got the
idea watching her but I knew there was
something important to sitting at the
desk and being in the classroom and I
wanted the audience to really feel that
way with this show I thought it would
make the stories we tell more poignant
if the people watching them felt like
they were at Abbott as well and that
kind of really sparked me like oh my God
yes finally an opportunity to use the
beauty of mockumentary I know this
school is rough but we may do
miss Coleman hello I'm the sub I thought
one of my colleagues here hired a
stripper for me
okay I can't but you know I think what's
fun about Abbott what I want to do is
just always have someone that no one is
expecting sometimes that's to me people
who are really talented that I'm just
obsessed with uh who I think are really
great to add to this show and then
sometimes it's people who I think just
no one will predict who fit into the
world I'm more into obscure guest stars
than like the perceived I don't know who
everyone expects I think it's exciting
to just have people from around Philly
or you know people are things from
around Philly I'm excited about the
guest stars oh God can someone please
help me down and why would we do that
since you clearly caused this situation
okay I didn't know doing this would
cause all the power to go out well the
power is not all out it's on in some
places and often others it's off in my
room definitely and I think a lot of
that is going to come from her working
on her outside life a little bit more
it'll make her skin a little bit thicker
in school there's a lot in store for her
but she's gonna get through it change
can be scary
but you know that better than anyone you
know as a sub you're here one day in a
totally different school tomorrow
well not anymore actually
just got this today
it remains to be seen I cannot I cannot
divulge that information there's going
to be some interesting stuff going on
with her fun stuff to see
I'm teaching a lesson on gravity
there have been three presidents since
this one here's where I taped in the
others
because they were incredible and they
made it only a day of filming when
someone throws hey we want you to play
Oprah that's a big deal and that was
just something I felt like I couldn't
say no to I love Weird Al I've loved him
since I was a kid it was an immediate
yes it almost was a no when they said
Oprah but then when I read the tone of
it I was like oh my God I can do this at
first I was like I'm too I can't play
Oprah but the tone of the movie is so
silly and perfect that I'm like this is
the exact way for me to honor Oprah
Winfrey in this beautiful silly comedy
it's just it was a great thing to be a
part of I love Daniel Radcliffe with I
mean do anything for that guy he's
really really a good person and I love
working with him I've worked with him on
miracle workers he's just a joy so yeah
it was an easy thing to show up for
Farmer Hank has seven turkeys then he
buys six more how many turkeys does
farmer Hank now have it's one of the
turkeys pregnant one of my kids asked
the same thing because it's a good
question was I surprised by the success
of the show no weirdly no I spend um as
actors we we always have to have an
optimism that the thing you're doing
might go well but in this particular one
from the very first script that made me
laugh and cry and it was something I
actually wanted to do I could see the
cultural plus of doing this show around
teachers it would have such a big
audience it would represent so many
people that are underrepresented it was
in a school in a world that is already
underrepresented and is diverse so all
of the reasons for it were great reason
to succeed but if it wasn't on the page
if it wasn't written in a way that uh
avoided being ham-fisted avoided being
preachy I I wouldn't have wanted to be
part of it it was truly funny and I
could see the characters and I told
Quinta when we were shooting the pilot
if all we get is teachers were a monster
hit but what we became was family for
our audience and they look forward to
spending every week with us they thought
of us as their family and that's the
sign of a truly good show is that people
feel like they're part of it that we are
part of their world and vice versa and
and become part of their world yes and
for all they look forward to watching it
with their different generations of
family members and I thought wow we are
we really could be that joke because we
felt that way with each other we're
destination TV right now plan their
lives around when we're on TV Wednesday
nights at nine o'clock and when you've
got all of these different people coming
together and it's not just in the United
States or in North America it is the
world yeah someone just said that they
were friends with uh teachers teaching
on Army bases in Germany and they
religiously watch the show every week so
it is and and people will write us and
when's it coming to England okay well
it's coming now so that part of it and I
have to say this and it's not just us as
a cast it is a success and a win and a
good feeling that created the world we
live in from every piece of our show
from props to the camera crew to set
design and costume design and our hair
and makeup who we adore all of the
elements root for it laugh when we're
doing our pieces when we're doing our
what we call the Talking Heads which are
the direct to camera pieces it's such an
atmosphere of support that I am not
surprised but I am truly truly grateful
all I'm hearing is
and yet Barb one of our best and most
senior teachers here she wait
what is your secret Barb knowing there's
not much you can do Ava I am so thrilled
that you know education has been my
husband's
lifelong passion education not just for
Philadelphia but for the state of
Pennsylvania because these state senator
Vincent Hughes of Philadelphia and for
me to be on this show that takes place
in Philadelphia written by a young
Philadelphian who loves her City because
you know a lot of folks from
Philadelphia oh they are passionate
about where they are from and to have my
husband working on this issue
and to hear him say to me that for the
first time in decades there is going to
be an increase to the funding of
Education in Philadelphia and
Pennsylvania and I dare say some of that
has to do with the fact that all of this
was put right out there for everybody to
see you must pay attention to these
broken toilets you must pay attention to
the lack of air conditioning in the
summer you must pay attention for the
funding that has been cut and not
available you must pay attention to the
need for books and supplies in the
classrooms of all of our children and
not just some so I'm so thankful that
show business and politics have come
together to do some real good for some
of the most important people ever her
and that's teachers and their students
and it I don't think it gets too much
better than that she's absolutely right
that passion permeates I think what all
of us do in my case yes you're right
it's personal
um my mother was a a teacher and she
started out her first job was in a
one-room schoolhouse in Pennsylvania my
father was getting his PhD at Penn State
and my mother taught in a school that
had kindergartners through seniors in
high school who would by the way not
come to class when
um when it was the Harvest because they
were they were Farm kids they were in
literally a one room like Shaq with an
outhouse
that was their toilet and they didn't
know she said that when they were
digging it when they were digging the
out the latrine for the Outhouse she had
to tell them you have to put a
downstream from the school
because the kids would go out and you
know Play In The Stream and get their
tadpoles and whatever but education is
education what you do you don't know
what you don't know
Hank has two turkeys he gets two more
how many turkeys he has four
I certainly hope so I'm waiting for my
soul yes you know Barbara Howard has a
completely different voice than Cheryl
Lee Ralph but I know she is waiting for
us all yes yeah uh-huh now I'm actually
teaching a lesson right now about the
unions in the city and how many of them
started in South Philly oh no way I know
some guys that were part of that
yeah I'm glad you're teaching that to
the kids
good job
well you know in the way that speaking
of my mom being a teacher Melissa is
tough her kids a
enjoy the fact that she's top children
I'm a mom of four there has to be some
sort of stability for kids to feel safe
so when there is a person in charge who
is who takes charge and make sure that
things are set the way they're supposed
to be kids are like okay I know what
we're doing here I feel safe with this
person who's in charge but if she's
going to be scary with anybody it's with
anybody who's is trying to do uh harm to
our kids she's going to be fight for
those kids which is something I saw my
mom do so is she tough yes she's tough
because she expects the most from her
kids but she's loving and she will hug
them as hard as she is hard on them she
will also hug them that hard you know
Melissa of course she's uh you know
Southern Philly type excuse me
talking about me
yeah I I was saying you are a a Southern
Philly type South Philly right somebody
came in who was
spiron from uh you know I went to school
in Maryland for a lot of years so you
know this this these O's are the same
it's more like Balmer O's so that part
was like easier but also there's like a
front of the mouth thing that's actually
just a physicality I I did a lot of
studying of
um Linguistics when I was in school I
think if I hadn't been an actor I would
have been like a dialect coach because I
find it fascinating about how dialects
develop the reason why Balmer and Philly
both have this sound were the immigrants
that peopled those areas who they were
it was they were German they were
Italian they were a very specific group
of people and they're both port cities
so there is a way that it developed
that's different from New York when my
parents are from New York so there are
certain sounds that are that are the
same but I did a lot of studying you
know people that think oh she they come
from Philly I'm not I did a lot of
studying I went online I listened to how
they say certain words if I see a
talking head where I know I have to say
something that's bully that might not be
in my uh toolbox
I will go and I'll research how the word
is said the writers are will write a
certain thing and I'll be like uh that's
not you know hey do you want to go it's
do you's want to go you guys want to
come
you know or GE uh you know if they say
something I'll be like no it's GE and
that is it's specific to Italians from
that area too so and that part is fun to
throw in because those those little
slang words I know from my family
Barbara yeah oh great work Buddy
let's get this little guy inside
oh thank you very much I appreciate it
it's an amazing time and it's the
perfect time the perfect show and thank
ABC and Warner Brothers for everything
and all the support that they have given
us and I don't think any of us will ever
forget our first award and that was a
hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes
we're going about this all wrong you
know you don't build a dam in the middle
of a Rushing River you build it before
the water comes that is so what the hell
are you talking about not by the success
but the every the the the
amount of success we want to be on TV
because they are covering underfunded
poorly managed public schools in America
no press is bad press Barb look at Mel
Gibson still thriving Daddy's home too
hilarious I hope this show has an impact
I mean I think first and foremost we're
interested in making people feel good
and representing something authentically
but that's kind of the weird thing about
what we do is like things catch on fire
and then you know person who's bagging
your groceries like knows you and like
saw your show and so I feel like just
the sheer amount of people that are now
like a part of our family or like are in
on this joke I feel like that has the
potential to to create change but yeah
we'll see I feel like it's still young
you'll be giving today's presentation
alone
uh oh my God what did he just say to you
that if you don't do well you're gonna
get fired worse
he mumbled and I didn't hear it she got
in a bit of trouble but then she got
herself out of it so there's no real uh
impetus to be a different person but I
feel like we also saw that in her own
way she contributes to the school that
she does care about the school in in the
way it's run in her own way perhaps that
Gregory may not even be a better
replacement than she I don't know let's
float that but
yeah so I feel like uh not only did she
get it get in a bit of trouble she
redeemed herself in the eyes of her
co-workers and to the viewers
oh
why is a man cooking ribs in my parking
spot what is happening it's getting gay
baby it's development week here's a
development you either got a park on the
street or give me fifty dollars for your
spot I'm making extra money for the
school if we are we haven't gotten to
that point in the in the script yet no
one tells me anything I talk too much so
I don't know we'll see more of that part
of Ava's life oh guys I need a new rug
mine is officially done me too I shook
mine out in all of the asthma kids had
to go to the nurse's office hey yo what
it do baby boos what y'all think about
this little film crew I brought in here
distracting makes our jobs harder I
don't think so and I mean not for me I
feel like I come from doing a lot of
theater and I feel like the way that we
shoot this show is actually more
conducive to capturing real life than
things usually are there's such a
symbiosis going on with all of us and
our camera operators and our producers
that it feels very easy now and a more
natural way of shooting things yeah I
was gonna say I have so so a few
experiences in front of the camera I'll
probably my next thing I'll have a
problem I'll be like this is in a
mockumentary you know
probably be looking into the camera but
no yeah like Chris said it feels very
natural sometimes not knowing things
lets you get into a new experience that
much easier I didn't have to unlearn
anything to to do this style of shooting
some of the kids are talking we gotta
catch one of them in the ACT then we
flip that kid followed up to the top
who wants to go fishing
okay well nobody is jumping up on my
desk so this is feeling like y'all's
problem it wasn't hard at all I hiking
and I'm just naturally talented at most
things no we all saw the legs I I am
even surprised that she even asked that
question we saw Josh oh so much fun I
hope there's more I hope there's more
yeah
that's one of my favorite episodes too
because it's very silly I can do a 21
Jump Street kind of thing if I put on
the right hat I could pull off 13. I
don't think so how about we get you some
platform shoes and you can pull off 12.
okay I can catch one of them
having done this kind of fishing in a
minute yeah we just shot one actually I
am the lucky contestant for it but yeah
I don't know I feel like we just kind of
get ideas sometimes stunt people will
probably go insane hearing this but
sometimes we just get ideas and like we
do things on the Fly and so whether
they're writing stunts for us or not
like who knows something something weird
is going to happen listen you're the new
guy here I am the second year vet I
figured I would you know show you a few
things around here no I'm just uh
looking so you've got Miss Cooper over
there I've been here a year and a half
she's been pregnant the whole time I
don't ask questions yeah I think I
pissed a lot of teachers off way back
then and so they've uh
disassociated not even not even a love
letter like Abbott Elementary could
could bring them back but but teachers
in general I I have that's not true I
actually am in touch with a couple
teachers that I had but but I have you
know heard from a lot of teachers that
did not have the privilege of
teaching me and that is really
meaningful I hear a lot that like they
feel like it's actually like that and
you know obviously we're going for
something slightly slightly heightened
in our show we're trying to make people
laugh but Quinta has always been
attached to and in pursuit of this idea
that it is genuine and authentic and and
when teachers tell us that that they
feel represented and that they feel like
it's actually like that that is the
biggest compliment
all right man you I can't do this I I
just don't like pizza what
say that again I don't think I heard you
son it just means that Joe you'll see a
lot more Mr Johnson I hope that Mr
Johnson is funnier than he was last year
I'm just happy and enjoying the the
moment enjoying the journey and I get to
come to work with some amazing actors
it's amazing incredible creative people
see this is why they'll never tell
anybody okay because everyone always
freaks out and acts like it's a personal
attack it's not my fault I Was Born This
Way don't you bring Lady Gaga into this
yeah
foreign
he doesn't like bacon will you learn Mr
Johnson's first name we'll see I I can't
tell you that that's a that's a secret
I'll go into a power pose
and remember you don't want to show too
much improvement because then they think
we won't need the money but then also
you don't want to show that we haven't
gotten any better because they didn't
think we're not capable of improvement
wow and this is the job you really want
well Ava's going to be able so I think
Ava and Gregory's relationship is going
to I think continue to have this is kind
of like underlying feeling of how
everyone feels about Ava which is
generally frustrated but at the end of
the day we got to make it work for this
school and I think at the end of last
year he really um decided to get on
board with helping her regardless of
whether or not he thinks she's good at
her job or if he should have it
memorization is How I Learned Over
States capitals Judo Salem Madison I
keep going in my class we do silly voice
time to you know break up the day and it
makes learning more fun too well for me
it's still
as an actor I've said this before
you you it's drilled and you do not look
into the camera do not look into the
camera so that's that's still been an
issue for me I'm learning to do it more
and to trust that okay even though it
looks like a camera that's a person so
deal with it deal with it as another
character the talking head part that's
uh actually it's fun I like it they
especially with Mr Johnson's character
because he can say anything he wants you
know yeah but but yeah the my community
style I think uh if it ain't broke don't
fix it you know
um yeah I think it's it's a very unique
style I really actually like it because
it you know I think we can get into
something I like to call like actor
speak where it just sounds like lines
and something about the mockumentary
format shakes that up
um it makes it feel realer to me and
that's where I think I find some of the
like more interesting quirks that
Gregory has it's something that I
haven't really done like that before but
is definitely now a new favorite genre
of mine look man I'm from Baltimore okay
all I know is when somebody roasts you
you gotta roast them back our teachers
used to roast Dustin if they didn't we
wouldn't have respected them you're just
getting clowns of course I'm being
clowned okay
100 of the show makes me regret
everything I did to my teachers yes all
of it like
we really do not fully understand how
hard of a job they have we have it on a
a very smaller scale but just trying to
Wrangle the kids in the room it's not
just like oh they're perfectly seated
there there's no we have to do it as a
set all of us and it feels like a school
in that way so trying to just get a show
done with that many kids is hard enough
trying to teach them how to read and
like write and become functional members
of society feels damn near impossible so
yeah for I was very talkative child I'm
so sorry I apologize all my thoughts and
questions did not need to be answered I
I grew up in a different a totally
different time I mean with with social
media and everyone has one of these
things the kids you know it's just a
whole different thing I can't imagine
what these teachers have to deal with
but yeah I put teachers through some
through some uh some Pace I'm not
supposed to say this because we're in a
different time in space now but you know
teachers used to paddle and now you that
word
because it's a Kinder word you know I
think every teacher in elementary school
had a little bit of my behind
[Music]
[Laughter]
I had fun though yeah yeah I had a I had
a good time very great in elementary
school